One fair wage!
Restaurant workers are being ripped off,
say these protesters because they aren't
guaranteed minimum wage.
In 43 states, employers are allowed to pay
tipped workers less,
some as little as $2.13 an hour.
Celebrities plus union protests convinced voters and
politicians in several states
that the government must insist on
a higher minimum for tipped workers.
This would be more fair for
all workers,
specifically for minorities and women.
They always say that it's to
"help minorities and women."
How is everything today?
But waitress Alcieli Felipe is a minority
and a woman.
Coffee?
She says,
don't change the rules on tips.
We have spaghetti and meatballs.
Thanks to tips,
Alcieli makes much more than minimum wage.
It's free refills, you're good.
I'll make $25 dollars an hour.
By the end of the year,
I made around $48 to $50 thousand dollars.
I'll take this for you.
If you raise the minimum wage,
it will be harder for restaurants
to keep the same amount of employees.
No, no say the so-called public interest lawyers.
We have to have a law.
The problem with tips is that they're very inconsistent.
Law professor Nicole Hallett leads social justice
protests,
this one demanding that
tipped workers be paid that higher minimum wage.
Require restaurant owners
to pay the same hourly wage
that all other employers have to pay.
Save our jobs!
But many restaurant workers say
don't raise the minimum,
a higher minimum
threatens our jobs.
The cost of having a restaurant
is not cheap.
For my boss to pay all her employees,
she would have to cut employees;
the busboy will be cut.
Hallett is unconvinced.
I simply don't believe that increasing the minimum wage
for tipped workers will lead in a reduction
in the restaurant workforce.
Studies have shown that
restaurants have been able to bear those costs.
Someone has to clear the plates.
But in New York after the last minimum wage increase,
270 restaurants closed.
But restaurants always close.
The industry is doing just fine.
Restaurants don't always close.
Michael Saltsman works for an employer group that
fights minimum wage increases.
Yeah, there's turnover in the industry.
But what we're doing now
is we're taking an industry
where there's low profit margins
we're dramatically increasing labor costs,
and we're jacking up restaurant closures.
If in the Bay Area,
you've got a 14% increase in restaurant closures
for each dollar increase in the minimum wage,
something's not right.
That isn't right,
but the media is all about workers
who are unhappy.
And go home with no money.
I don't think that it's fair for a worker to
struggle to pay rent, to struggle to meet groceries.
One study found that 46 percent
of tipped workers nationwide
rely on public benefits.
Like food stamps.
But even Hallett admits many are only eligible because
a lot of people don't report tipped income.
Many restaurants and restaurant workers
often don't report 100% of their income.
So the fact they're getting benefits
doesn't mean anything,
it just means that they're cheating the taxpayer.
Alcieli says she doesn't cheat
but many other people do.
Lots of people make cash money, tip only.
Tons of restaurants do that.
Have a great day hon.
Those who demand higher minimums also claim
eliminating tips will reduce sexual harassment,
another argument embraced by the media.
90% of restaurant workers
report experiencing sexual behavior
that is scary or unwanted.
90%?
90%.
Tipping is pretty dependent on her willingness
to touch or be touched.
This'll reduce sexual harassment.
Sexual harassment has nothing to do
with the state's tipping system,
and it's not me saying that,
it's the federal government saying that.
A study using federal data
did find that states that raised the minimum
actually had
Increases in sexual harassment.
The states that did what you want, there are more
charges of sexual harassment.
Sexual harassment is a very complicated problem
and no single policy is going to
eliminate that problem.
Ok, so raising the minimum
probably won't affect sexual harassment,
but it will force some restaurants to fire workers
and force some to close.
Since prices will be higher, tips will go down.
This is supposed to be good for restaurant workers?
Save our jobs!
No wonder so many opposed
what the activists demand.
Just keep as it is,
we are fine.
Who are those people,
have they worked in a restaurant industry?
She hasn't
and all this makes me ask,
why should there be any minimum?
Why can't the employer and the employee
make whatever deal they want?
Well, that policy has been rejected.
It's
something that has been rejected
for the last hundred years and
we're not in that world right now.
We sure aren't.
We're in a world where activists and government
protect workers,
even when they don't want
that protection.